Man kann ganz leicht inkompetent aussehen, indem man einfach immer so übertrieben nach unten guckt, so als würde man irgendwie unter einer Brille durchschauen. Wenn du irgendwie irgendwo hinguckst, wenn du auf dein Handy guckst und den Hals so ein bisschen reckst und dann so von oben runter guckst, wirkst du direkt wie so ein inkompetenter Lappen einfach. Ich finde auch dieses Brille abnehmen und das Handy weiter weghalten, wenn man was lesen will, was ich mittlerweile glaube ich auch habe. Ich bin mittlerweile auch, fange ich an, weitsichtig zu werden, halte mein Handy so ein bisschen weiter von mir weg, dass alle um mich herum sehen können, was ich gerade für ein YouTube-Video schaue, in der Bahn. Aber dieses weit weggucken, wenn ich jemanden fragen würde, wenn ich Stephen Hawking fragen würde, erklär mir doch mal, was mit den schwarzen Löchern da war, und er dann was nachlesen muss und dieses weite Wegrecken hat, würde ich sagen, komm, lass es einfach, lass es. Was da jetzt rauskommt, ist wie nur Bullshit. Das ist genau so, wenn du zum Arzt gehst und sagst, ich habe meinen Arm gebrochen und der nimmt erstmal die Brille ab und guckt sich in den Arm und denkt, komm, komm, das ist mein Bein, tschau, ich habe schon jetzt keinen Bock mehr, vergessen wir es, tschau, da sind wir doch auch schon beim Thema, Arzt, Wartezimmer, toll. Hast du schon mal einen Arzt gerage quittet? Bist du schon mal gesagt, ja, dann lassen wir es halt. Nee, ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Person diese Person bei mir immer einnimmt, sobald ich komme. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, bin ich beim Roast von Jeff and Tietze, oder was ist jetzt los? Machen Sie Sport. Wie oft bin die Frage gestellt, ob ich rauche? So ganz seltsam. Warum kommt die Frage denn bitte auf? Das sieht halt aus wie so ein cooler Raucher. Typ der raucht, der hat mal so ein Glimmstängel in der Wange einfach da angeritten. Dann kommt immer so, trinken Sie, rauchen Sie. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, danach will der Arzt sagen, du bist echt ein Nerd. Du bist ein uncooler Nerd. Weißt du was? Lebt mal! Unabhängig davon, dass du Lebra hast, bist du echt ein Lappen, einfach so. Ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige, bei dem der Arzt nachher sagt, du solltest mal unbedingt eine rauchen. Also, dir würde es gut tun, mal eine zu rauchen. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, aber ich war lange nicht mehr beim Arzt. Ich war auch richtig lange nicht mehr beim Arzt. Auch seit ich in Köln wohne, war ich mit dem Arzt auch aus Angst so ein bisschen, weil in der Stadt, wo du aufwächst, wirst du mit dem Arzt gewisserweise gross, weil du die, du musst Vorsorgeuntersuchungen, Nachsorgeuntersuchungen, hast du mal Zahnspange oder sowas. Das heißt, du lernst deine Ärzte von Geburt auf kennen und wächst mit denen auf und du hast Vertrauen zu denen. Aber in der neuen Stadt plötzlich hier, ich suche mir keinen Hausarzt mehr oder ich suche mir auch keinen Zahnarzt oder so. Nee, ich gehe einfach dann, entweder gehe ich zu Hause in meiner Heimat über die Feiertage oder sowas, oder ich lasse es einfach.
Ja, man hat auch so das Gefühl, dass man das nicht mehr so, als Kind muss man so noch ganz oft neu tariert werden, irgendwie wenn du so ein neues iPhone, dann schaust du noch ganz oft bei Tutorials nach und guckst so, ah, wie macht man das, aber alles, was du so nach einem Monat nicht mehr verstehst, ist auch egal. Also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, irgendwie mein Rücken tut echt we weh, würde ich sagen, da habe ich jetzt den Moment verpasst, wo ich das hätte richten können, damit muss ich jetzt einfach leben. Aber ansonsten glaube ich das letzte Mal ... Wann entscheidest du denn konkret, diese Schmerzen sind es wert, von einem Fachmann untersucht zu werden? Nie, also ich war, keine Ahnung. Aber das letzte Mal war ich tatsächlich beim Ohrenarzt und da ist es sehr unangenehm, weil ganz am Schluss, wenn du sozusagen verabschiedet wirst, unabhängig davon, dass du kein Wort verstehst und einfach wild irgendwie der Toppflanze die Hand gibst oder sowas, also habe ich als Gag versucht, kam nicht so gut an, aber da wurde dann so gefragt, was machen sie denn beruflich? Weil wenn du zum Beispiel Koch bist oder so oder irgendwie was mit Hygiene zu tun hast, wo andere Leute drunter leiden können, dann darfst du nicht arbeiten,
nachdem du irgendwie so eine Entzündung hattest im Ohr oder so ein Gedöns. Das hat man mir im Nachhinein erklärt. Ich dachte, das ist einfach nur so ein, ja, in unserem Beruf ist es ja oft so ein bisschen schwierig, so ein bisschen, ja, ich bin Comedian, also, naja, also die FAZ hat geschrieben, Comedian und Autor. Ich persönlich sehe mich jetzt mehr als Entrepreneur, aber auf der anderen Seite, ja gut, Lebenskünstler, was heißt das? Du musst Entrepreneur nicht noch französischer ausbrechen. Aber das ist so eine Antwort, man ist auf einer anderen Ebene, mit so einer Rezensionistin beim Arzt, die einfach nur wissen will, ist es hygienisch relevant oder nicht so und die einfach sagt, nein, okay, sie können gehen.
Ich hätte exakt die neuste Situation, als ich mal wieder, das ist ungelogen, zum achten Mal mit PayPal telefoniert habe und dann plötzlich... Man kennt sich mittlerweile.
Plötzlich, am unangenehmsten ist es immer, wenn ich unsere E-Mail-Adresse zentrale-podcast-ufo.fail durchgeben muss, was immer zum grossen...
Bitte was, wiederholen Sie das mal? Nein, Sie haben mich schon verstanden.
Sie akzeptieren das noch nicht als
legitimate E-Mail-Adresse.
Und dann hat er ganz am Ende,
bevor er mich dann zur Rechtsabteilung
irgendwo in den achtzehnten Stock
durchgestellt hat, hat er dann die Frage gestellt,
was ist das eigentlich für ein Podcast?
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, wir machen Comedy und so.
Warum muss er das fragen?
Er meinte, aus privatem Interesse, was ist das für ein Podcast?
Ja, Comedy.
Dann waren so zehn Minuten still und dann
Vielen Dank. Er sagt, ja, wir machen Comedy und so. Warum muss er das fragen? Er meinte, aus privatem Interesse. Was ist denn das für ein Podcast? Ja, Comedy. Dann waren so zehn Minuten still und dann, ich stelle sie durch. Und dann war das Gespräch vorbei. Aber so, als ob er noch ein Gespräch anfangen wollte, dann enttäuscht wurde und mich noch umstehen würde. Wo du das Gefühl hast, bei jeder anderen Antwort wäre das Gespräch weitergegangen. Nur das, was du konkret gesagt hast, hat es einfach so Comedy. Ich stelle sie durch. Tut mir leid, dass mein Leben nicht beeindruckend genug ist für Sie, Herr IT-Support an der Hotline bei Telekom. Gestern habe ich Essen bekommen und ich wurde neben der Pathologie. Und dann kam halt der Fudoramann rein, hat gesagt, oh, sie wurden direkt neben der Pathologie. Wahnsinn. Ich so, ja, ich traue mich auch nicht, von denen Pakete anzunehmen. Und der hat sich kaputt gelacht. Der hat noch nie, es war, der hat mich zu spätet, deswegen kam erst um zehn Uhr irgendwann das Essen an, also sehr spät schon. Es war schon Nachtruhe eingekehrt im Haus, würde ich mal behaupten. Und er hat das Treppenhaus zusammengeschrien, weil er es so lustig fand. Ich habe noch nie einen Menschen so sehr zum Lachen gebracht, glaube ich. Der fand das so den lustigsten Gag aller Zeiten. Und er hat einfach wirklich lauthals gelacht. Ich hab ihn noch durch die Straße mit dem Fahrrad wegfahren, lachend wegfahren hören. Aber hat er sich so gesteigert, oder hat er von der ersten Sekunde an auf voller Dezibel gelacht? Es war plötzlich Stille, Stille, und die Dezibel sind in die Luft gegangen. Und dann hat man ... Also, der Lautstärke blieb bei, als er wegfuhr langsam. Ich glaube auch, es ist so, du machst einen Gag und dann, wenn man sich die Reaktionen als Grafen anschaut, kein Lachen ist peinlich, dann je mehr Lachen, desto angenehmer, dann gibt es einen gewissen Punkt, der erreicht ist, wo man sagt, okay. Und dann soll das wieder abflauen. Und dann flaut es wieder ab, weil zu viel Lachen ist auch nicht gut. Es hat nicht aufgehört, es war zu laut. Erstmal denkt man, das ist ironisch, aber dann denkt man sich so, hey, weißt du, wenn du so wenig Humor hast, dass du das jetzt so lustig findest, dann wird dein Lachen auch weniger wert, dann ist dein Lachen nichts wert, dann ist das keine Bestätigung. Abgesehen davon, dass dein Leben eh nichts wert ist, wenn ich esse einen Foodorapher, der Essen bringt. Lächerlich. Vor allem, es gibt diesen Moment, wenn die Foodorapher einen Essen bringt, der so ein bisschen unangenehm ist. Und zwar machen sie ja dann, gehen sie zu dir in die Haustür, du machst sie auf, dann knien sie sich hin, machen ihre grosse Box auf, müssen dann im Knien, in dieser furchtbaren, mir untergebenden Stellung, mir das Essen aus ihrer komischen, würfelförmigen Box holen, holen das Essen da raus, geben es mir, und gebe ich denen das Trinkgeld und dann knien sie aber noch vor mir, weil sie noch die Box zumachen müssen. Ich habe das Essen aber schon. Für mir ist die Transaktion beendet. Ich mache dann immer schon, dann überlege ich immer, kann ich jetzt schon die Tür zumachen, während sie noch vor mir ein Haus zu knien? Ah, das ist gut, ja, oder muss sie jetzt aufstehen lassen? Das ist so ein ganz komischer Moment, ich kann sie nicht aufstehen lassen, weil sie oft extrem lange brauchen, um diese fucking Würfelkoffer wieder zuzumachen,
um die wieder auf ihren Rücken zu nehmen.
Das machen die alles im Knien, im Liegen vor mir.
Meistens verbringen die wahrscheinlich
noch zehn Minuten vor meiner Haustür, ehe ich die schon zugemacht habe.
Aber das ist halt echt ein Problem einfach.
Wann gibst du da genau Trinkgeld?
Bevor die wieder aufstehen oder danach?
Nee, während sie mir das Essen geben.
Du hast es schon lange geregt.
In einer Handbewegung mache ich das so. Ich nehme das Essen und gebe was. Nehmen und geben, gleichzeitig. Und dann knien Sie aber die ganze Zeit vor mir. Und dann mache ich immer so, ja, schönen Abend noch. Dann machen wir so langsam die Haustür. Ich mache sie wirklich dann betont langsam zu, damit es nicht so ein Rumsgefühl hat. Es ist aber unangenehm, weil Sie knien die ganze Zeit vor. Ja, es ist auch so einem vielleicht so einem Kann-ich-ih-ihnen-Helfen-Blick so, ah, wenn sie jetzt nichts sagen, dann heißt es nein, rausgehen, irgendwie so ist es schwierig. Ich kann nicht nachvollziehen. Genau, und dann war die Tür halt zu und er hat noch draußen gelacht, was auch ein bisschen unangenehm war einfach gestern. Aber das ist auch wirklich ein bisschen komisch, dieses Essen wäre offensichtlich eh schon untergeben, weil seine Dienstleistung mir zuteil wird. das ist ja offensichtlich, habe ich gerade einen höheren Status, weil ich der Kunde bin, aber dann hat es noch dieses Demütende Hinknien, das tut mir auch mal so ein bisschen leid.
Ey, und da muss ich auch echt nochmal sagen, richtig krasse Props, richtig grossen Respekt an die SS und die Nazis im Allgemeinen, wie die es geschafft haben, so souverän auch ihre Macht auszuüben und wirklich Autorität gegenüber anderen auszuüben. Weil es ist nicht leicht, ich bin mit dem Zug gefahren und ich habe einen neuen Level der ICE-Kunst freigeschaltet. Ich bin mit dem Begriff, ich bin mit dem Zug gefahren, nach einer SS-Lobrennen. Ich bin mit dem Zug gefahren und ich habe jetzt das Abteil für mich entdeckt. Nicht mehr Gang, nicht mehr Grossraum, sondern Abteil, weil tatsächlich auch im Abteil Gleichgesinnte sitzen. Leute, die ihre Ruhe haben wollen, gehen ins Abteil und dann kannst du auch eher deine Ruhe haben. Oh Gott, warum kommen jetzt denn Mailgeräusche auf unser Ohr massiv laut auf unsere Kopfhörer? Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die auf der Aufnahme auch drauf sind. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wir reden hier, also wenn man von außen uns mal kurz betrachtet, wir sitzen hier mit Mikrofonen und Kopfhörnern auf dem Tisch, reden die ganze Zeit ruhig und zwischendurch schrecken wir so hoch einfach beide und reden dann nochmal weiter, einfach weil so ein Mail-Sound kommt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall habe ich das Abteil für mich entdeckt und das ist wirklich fantastisch. Aber die Situation war so, ich kam rein und der Zug war komplett voll, Leute standen schon auf dem Gang, überall rumgesessen und ich hatte einen Abteilplatz reserviert und das Abteil, sechs Leute und es war voll. Alle saßen da und auf meinem Platz saß eine junge Frau, die gerade studiert hat, also die gerade gelernt hat und hatte wirklich Laptop-Vorsicht stehen, ein dickes Buch auf dem Schoß. Maximal ausgebreitet, geil! Ja, wirklich ein dickes Buch auf dem Schoß mit so wirklich so chemischen Formeln, so Verbindungen und so wirklich komplett ausgebreitet, so wirklich auch so die Jacke um sich rum, so zwischen sich und die Lehne. Das ist so ein kleines Filmentschöns von dir. Die Lösung ist drei und du sitzt auf meinem Platz.
Ja, genau. Und dann so, und es war mir so, ich bin dreimal davor hin und her gelaufen, und ich habe auch dann so hilfesuchende Blicke zu den anderen im Abteil, die natürlich überhaupt gar keine Ahnung hatten, was der Sache war. Und ich habe dann immer so, so auf die gedeutet, aber die wussten natürlich nicht, was los ist. Und dann irgendwann habe ich aufgemacht und dann so, wirklich alle gucken mich an, weil die Abteil war ja schon voll. Ja, ein bisschen Dementor bist du da vorhergeschlagen für den Teil. Ja, genau, aber die Frage war, warum macht jetzt noch jemand die Tür auf, das ist voll. Und deswegen haben alle die Aufmerksamkeit auf mich gerichtet und ich dann so wirklich überall hinweg so, entschuldigen Sie, Sie sitzen auf meinem Platz und die guckt mich so ratlos an so und dann der Typ, der neben ihr sass, schuppt ihn so an so, mio, mio comprendo, so. Und ich dachte mir, Gott, sie spricht kein Deutsch, das kann nicht wahr sein. Nein. Das kann nicht wahr sein, sie spricht einerseits kein Deutsch. You're sitting on my place. Und die Person neben ihr gehört zu ihr. Das heißt, wenn ich sie jetzt rausschmeiße, habe ich die getrennt. Das ist Ehepaar oder diese Beziehung habe ich getrennt. Oh nein. Und er spricht Deutsch und sie nicht. Und dann eher so Ah, Jo, honey, Jo, Jo, Jo, honey. Jo, honey. Hey, Jo, honey, what's up? It's Berlin 2017. You're sitting on his place. Und dann sie so, oh, really? Das ist der Abteil-Rap. Eine Welt ist zusammen. Oh, really? Oh, I'm so sorry. Und ich so, I'm so fucking sorry, really. Und dann hat die Person, die daneben saß, gesagt so, ah, nee, ist schon okay, ich stehe auf, damit die beiden zusammenbleiben können. Dann ist die andere Person aufgestanden. Für dich, damit du auf den Seiten... Die anderen beiden sind zusammen ein Stück rübergerückt und ich konnte mich auf den Freiwilligen Platz setzen. Das heißt, die hat sich... Du warst der Unsympath. Du warst der Villain in der Geschichte. Diese andere junge Frau, die nichts mit der Situation zu tun hat, hat sich mehrtürerhaft vor dieses Liebespaar geworfen. Was so zerstörend im Begriff war, zu zerstören. Ja, hat sich geopfert und dann hat sie auch nochmal gesagt so,
no, no, you can just sit there und so wirklich, wie so ein Flüchtling der da gerade so,
oh, werde ich jetzt deportiert und ich
wirklich so musste mich dann noch durch alle so
durchquetschen, auch mit der Jacke und ich habe dann noch so
ein Beute dabei. Und dann 18 Stunden neben ihnen sitzen.
Genau, und Fargo gucken, auf dem
Laptop, während sie mit ihrem Laptop
dann so irgendwie versucht, chemische Formeln
zu lernen, um dann irgendwie den Abschluss zu bekommen. Damit sie ihr Visum zu bekommen. Und es war auch nicht wirklich, I'm so sorry. Und da bin ich zehn Minuten danach, dachte ich, fuck, ich muss aufs Klo, aber ich kann jetzt nicht nochmal aufstehen und alles. Fuck, es ist doch nicht mein Platz. Können Sie bitte auf mein Laptop aufbauen? Das Beste, wenn du dich nur vertan hättest. Und sie gar nicht auf deinen Platz sah, sondern sie rechtmäßig diesen Platz an. Genau, dann kommt der Kontrolleur und so, ja, das ist erste Klasse, sie haben kein Ticket für die erste Klasse. Oh, Entschuldigung, ach so, ja dann, sorry, Fargo zumachen. Oh nein. Aber das ist tatsächlich so, und dann habe ich dann... Aber wenn du kommst, weißt du, wenn du kommst, dann wird auch die, diese Gläser werden zu Eis. Und dann kommst du so, und dann kommt Florin, die nur um die Ecke und alle, fuck, Dementor. Und ich sauge allen so ein bisschen lebensfreude aus dem Leib. Dementor? Aber das ist dann tatsächlich so, wenn du dann sitzt und du hast dein Laptop offen und du weißt ja alle, die neben dir sitzen und im Abteil sitzen sogar zwei Leute neben dir, nicht nur eine Person, die gucken ja an, was du auf deinem Laptop machst und in dem Moment denkst du dir, ja fuck, jetzt hab ich den Tisch ihr weggenommen, jetzt muss ich irgendwas Wertvolles mit dem Laptop machen, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach irgendwie eine Folge Ren and Stimpy gucken, wie ich es sonst mache. Ich muss jetzt, und dann hatte ich für DSA das Schwarze Auge, das Pernopper-Rollenspiel, da habe ich teilweise so Tabellen angelegt, so wie man, welche Talente man steigern soll und welche Zauber man in welcher Reihenfolge. Und maximal auch ganze Wirken so, was du machst da mit Chemie und den Formeln, ich kenne auch undurchsichtige Dinge. Ey, aber ich liebe es auch, Drehbücher offen zu haben. Das auch. Ich liebe das im Zug Drehbücher. Ich muss nicht mal daran schreiben, aber es ist einfach ein cooles Gefühl, weil Leute immer so rübergucken. In der Aaron Sorkin Masterclass eine Sache, die Aaron Sorkin als Tipp gibt für junge Drehbuchautoren ist, schau dir einen Film an, den du gerne magst und lese parallel das Skript. Also hab das Skript auf deinem Schoss und liess parallel, wie sich das übersetzt hat. Und das habe ich auch teilweise gemacht. Dann hatte ich auf meinem Laptop den Film laufen lassen, keine Ahnung, Social Network oder so und hatte parallel als PDF das Skript offen. Und ich habe mich noch nie so cool gefühlt wie in der Situation, weil die Person, die neben einem sitzt, denkt sich Wow, Alter! Ich habe ja auch schon viele Filme gesehen, aber Wow! Noch nie mit einem sen Drehbuch daneben. Das, was ich aus Spaß mache, macht der irgendwie auf eine Art auch professionell oder cool. Ja, und Potentials. Und ich dachte mir so, yeah, dann habe ich immer so gescrollt, dann habe ich teilweise auch angehalten, den Film angehalten. Und dann nochmal nachgeguckt. Genau, und angehalten, dann nachgeguckt und dann habe ich Dinge markiert. Ja, wow. Völlig nutzlos. Ein Und markiert. Oder du bist ein bisschen aufgefallen. Genau, die Seitenzahlen markiert. Aber zu schreiben ist noch ein bisschen geiler. Tatsächlich einfach wesentlich geiler. Das stimmt schon. Aber da muss er dann tatsächlich arbeiten. Das ist dann ein bisschen schwierig. Naja, gut, was ich schon für Skripte geschrieben habe, einfach weil ich das gerade machen wollte, das will ich schon nicht lesen. Das stimmt, ja. Da bräuchte es auch so eine Software, es gibt ja so eine Hacker-Software, wo man einfach wild auf der Tastatur rumdrückt und dann erscheint so ganz viel Code. Und sowas müsste es für Drehbautorne auch geben, dass du einfach willkürlich tippst und da entsteht dann irgendwie das Skript zu Pulp Fiction oder so und da denkst du, boah krass, das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor. Und dann kommt der Fahrkartenkontrolleur und du drehst dich um und suchst dein Handy raus, um dir ein Ticket zu geben, aber magicerweise schreibt sie einfach ganz normal das Skript weiter. Oder er bastelt dich so, Moment, das ist nicht ihr Skript. Dann auch vorkommen. Ich habe tatsächlich auch ein Sprachenproblem gehabt, ich war mal, das ist ein bisschen länger, ich war Lasertag spielen. Also ganz normal, ganz normales Hobby, ich liebe Lasertag-Spielen. Das ist eine Technik von Stefan Tietze, dass er die Story so einleitet, dass er innerhalb der Story nicht mehr uncooler werden kann. Dass er, wenn er mit der Prämisse schon anfängt, das genau so hatten wir heute auch ein Gespräch, wenn Leute ihr Gespräch beginnen mit, ich glaube, das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt, aber sichern Sie sich einfach nur ab. Abgeschaltet. Selbst wenn das die langweiligste Story der Welt ist, du kannst sagen, ja, ich habe dich ja vorgewarnt. Und so macht es Tesla auch. Wir gucken mal, wie es weitergeht. Nee, aber tatsächlich war ich Lasertag spielen und da gibt es am Anfang, gibt es ja dann für Leute, die das noch nie gemacht haben, gibt es so eine kleine Einweisung. Da gibt es sowas wie, die werden die Regeln erklärt. Ich bin schon zum dritten Mal hier, muss ich die Einweisung trotzdem mitmachen? Stefan, bitte, bleib einfach noch kurz hier. Wir wissen, dass du hier sehr oft bist, zu oft für meinen Geschmack. Ich hab mein eigenes Equipment dabei, kann ich das jetzt schon anziehen oder kann ich das erst mit den anderen bei den Schränken anziehen? Schaltet seine Waffe aus, der Mensch. Ich hab bei meiner Lasergun, ich hab noch zusätzliche LEDs angebracht. Wenn ihr coolen sein wollt, müsst ihr fragen, spielen wir mit Minen oder ohne? Weil oben in der Ecke sind manchmal Minen, die euch abfeuern, wenn ihr die nicht vorher ausschaltet. Andere Geschichte. Naja, und es ist halt, tatsächlich ist es aber, das ist ganz cool, es macht echt Spaß. Es tut nicht so weh wie mit Paintball. Das ist das, das ist das Silly. Es ist ganz geil, es macht auch echt Spaß, wenn man abends kein cooler Film macht. Mit den Jungs mal raus, mit den Jungs mal schön, die alle, ein bisschen Tänken, ein bisschen Tänken, ja klar, es macht Spaß. Nein, klar, einfach mal schön mit einem Backlight einfach mal da sitzen und dann irgendwie einen schönen Coke Zero schlürfen und dabei einfach ein bisschen taggen. Ist auch klar, währenddessen läuft Blink-182 und danach gucken wir noch ein bisschen Starship. We all in this together, once we know. Und dann war es halt so, die Regeln sind nicht so ganz unkompliziert, weil du halt so ein paar Regeln beachten musst, darfst du hinknien, darfst nicht rennen und so, was viele denken, dass man das nicht machen darf. Wer den wenigsten Sex in den letzten sechs Monaten hatte, gewinnt, das sind die Regeln. Das ist die eigentliche Regel. Aber dann kam es halt zu dem Problem, dass Leute, die mit denen wir da gespielt haben, Spanier waren. Man konnte denen nicht ganz so gut erklären, was da jetzt genau läuft.
Und sie waren nicht nur, ich glaube, die wollten auch gar nicht da sein, die wollten im Supermarkt oder so schwimmen gehen, weiß ich nicht. Es waren aber nicht nur Spanier, sie waren auch gehörlos. Es waren gehörlose Spanier. Das sind die schlimmsten Spanier. Und dann habe ich es erfahren, durch irgendwie Magic oder Gedankenübertragung wusste ich plötzlich, dass es gehörlose Spanier waren. Und ich habe mich so gefreut auf den Blick von diesem Typen, der denen erklären musste, wie das Spiel funktioniert. Und drehe mich so langsam um zu dem und er einfach so Schweissgebadet. Also ich weiß nicht, also wir haben ja diese We have this und dann einfach nur so große Bewegung draufgezeigt, als würde das irgendwie erklären, wie das funktioniert, einfach so gross draufzeigen, das ist hier diese Pistole und ihr müsst einfach Well, you have to, well, this is the Tango und naja, die waren so ein bisschen, ich habe noch nie so hoch gewonnen. Ich hätte, glaube ich, den Highscore für diesen Laden an dem Abend, weil man die einfach, es waren Ziele, es waren Kanonenfutter, die waren Kanonenfutter, die liefen einfach die ganze Zeit rum, man wusste nicht genau, wie das läuft und es waren einfach sehr einfache Ziele. Und das war echt unangenehm, die haben die Regeln halt nicht ganz verstanden, was aber ganz geil war. Ich war dann nochmal da und dann waren, das macht Spaß, ich bin da ja gerne, ich bin auf Lasertacken. Und man muss auch vorher mal anrufen, weil man will ja nicht alleine spielen. Kumpel und ich wollten halt Lasertacken abends. Und dann waren da halt keine Gruppen mehr frei. Und dann hieß es ja, ihr könnt euch einer Gruppe anschließen. Dann kamen wir aber zu spät an, es hat sich herausgestellt, es war ein Kindergeburtstag. Wir kamen zu spät, haben die alle abgeschossen die ganze Zeit, haben denen auch so Richtungen angezeigt, damit die einfach ins offene Feuer laufen und wir dann andere ausschalten können und so. Einmal so Kanonen als Kanonenfutter benutzt, die kleine Lisa, den kleinen Malte.
So, und dann, fuck you, haben die alle abgeschossen, sind dann raus, haben die gefragt, wollt ihr noch eine Runde spielen?
Alle so, nein, wir haben kein Geld mehr und sind gegangen, die wurden abgeholt, die wurden abgeholt und sind gefahren.
Wir sind zu spät hingekommen, die mussten warten auf uns. Wir haben alle abgeschossen, haben gefragt, wollt ihr noch eine Runde spielen?
Und sie haben gesagt, nein, wir haben leider kein Geld mehr. Und sie wurden von ihren Eltern abgeholt. Das war deren Abend. Das war deren Kindergeburtstag. Das war deren Kindergeburtstag. Was für Arschlöcher. Ah, das stimmt schon. Aber der ist schon ganz geil. Ich dachte mir gerade, bei Taube Spanier, das kürzt sich ja irgendwie raus. Weil wenn die Taube, ist es auch scheißegal, ob es Spanier oder Okulelen sind, weil die verstehen eh kein Wort. Aber manche können ja Lippen lesen, das heißt, wenn du den auf Englisch Lippen lesen, also auf Deutsch Lippen lesen ist es einfacher, als wenn du plötzlich Spanisch, deutlich Spanisch sprechen musst. Kann sein, ja, du kannst dann nur so mit so Rasseln, kannst du dann nur Zeichen sprechen. Du kennst ihn ja auch auf der Tafel, die haben es ja auch tatsächlich für für Gehörlose haben die dann die Regeln auf so grossen Monitoren zum Nachlesen gepackt.
Aber dadurch, die gibt es halt nicht auf Spanisch. Und das war echt ein Problem dann einfach. Die konnten das nicht verstehen.
Stimmt, das ist interessant. Ich arbeite ja gerade an einem Prank-YouTube-Kanal. Kann man auch so machen, so dann irgendwie bei einer Stewardess dann so.
Können Sie das nochmal meinem Opa erklären, der ist leider blind und taub. Der ist blind und taub und afghane. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Sorry. Nee, aber auch, so gehörlose Sachen sind auch echt ganz interessant. Ich habe neulich eine Folge Family Liga geguckt und da stand drunter für Gehörlose, ich habe die, irgendwie waren die Gehörlose untertit Landen, da stand dann drin Peter spielt La Cucaracha. Und da dachte ich mir auch, für Leute, die halt taub geboren sind, ist diese Information wenig hilfreich. Das stimmt, ja. Peter spielt La Cucaracha. Was denken die dann, was er spielt? das sieht auch nicht Er singt Staying Alive von den Bee Gees, ja.
Das geht so.
Staying Alive.
So die Noten werden.
Wahrscheinlich, aber die Person, die, ich meine, wenn du Family Guy
transkribierst
für den gehörlosen Markt, man muss
sich wahrscheinlich so zusammenreißen, da keine Gigs einzubauen.
Weil ich meine, wenn du für Family Guy arbeitest
oder in dem Bereich, bis zum Frechdachs, und dann, glaube ich, hast du immer so die Versuchung, dann irgendwie so falsche Sachen und so, oh, Hilfe, mein Finger steckt in der gehörlosen Maschine fest, Hilfe, Hilfe, bitte, ruf mich an, Blowjob, Blowjob, einfach, oh, scheiße, ist alles kaputt gerade. Oh, die Folge geht ja schon los, oh, nein. Oh, nein, Hilfe. Hey, sag mal, hast du noch einen Stift für mich? Hey, sei ruhig, ich versuche gerade, die zu übersetzen. Oh scheiße, sorry, ich rufe dich später nochmal an. Ja, okay, gut, dann wo war ich? Und dann solche Sachen.
Klar, ihr versteht schon, was ihr da habt. Ihr versteht schon.
Ich glaube, unsere Community ist mittlerweile so gag-sicher, dass wir die auch gar nicht zu Ende erklären werden.
Wir sagen einfach demnächst sowas wie, ja hier, Kopfhörer, Wireless und Go.
Apropos Community, es macht wieder sehr viel Spaß, sich in der Puffopedia zu bewegen, die reichlich, wenn da gefüllt wird. Noch mehr Spaß würde es mit Bildern machen. Ja, irgendwie sind noch keine Bilder dabei, die Puffopedia.info. Und noch mehr Spaß würde es ohne Rechtschreibfehler machen. Ich habe aber auch schon gehört, dass wir den ersten Bot-Angriff hinter uns haben. Also die erste Bot-Welle wurde abgewehrt von den tapferen Wächtern der Pupup-Pedia. Die erste Welle, aber macht euch berat. Bringt euch in Sicherung. Nehmt die Verletzten, nehmt die Verletzten, kümmert euch drum. Es ist aber wirklich so der erste Schritt im Krieg gegen die Maschinen sind Bot-Angriffe, weil ich habe irgendwie fünf WordPress-Blogs, die ich betreue, und manche muss sich teilweise aufgeben. Einen schlechter als die anderen. Weil einfach so viele Spam-Kommentare kommen und du der nicht herwürst irgendwann. Und das ist wirklich schwierig, aber dass sie einfach gewisse Sachen kontaminiert haben. Dass du irgendwann sagst, ja, man kann einfach keine WordPress-Blogs mehr machen, weil die die irgendwann einfach zerreissen unter der puren Last der Spams. Das hat ja gar keine inhaltliche Relevanz, sondern einfach die alleine Datenmengel. Warum machen die das denn? Keine Ahnung, weil die halt irgendwie
Klicks haben wollen, dass man halt irgendwie auf
Scheiß links klickt oder so ein Crap.
Aber ich glaube,
die Bot-Industrie macht auch viel falsch.
Also die Bot-Industrie,
die macht halt, also die begibt halt
alles dafür, um sofort aufzufliegen.
Diese ganzen WordPress-Kommentare, wo ich
teilweise Stunden am Tag dran sitze, um die
wegzulöschen, die sind halt alle halt, fangen mit xxxx Viagra xxx an, wo ich mir denke, wenn ihr das wirklich verkaufen wollt, dann schreibt doch einfach was anderes rein.
Aber ich glaube, das ist eine Art von Spam, wo die wirklich drauf bauen, dass du wirklich Interesse hast.
Aber ich habe letztens zum Beispiel, ich habe das perfekte Spam bekommen.
Ich hatte neulich einen Spam, wo ein ganz normaler Satz drin stand, er ist so, hey, ich finde euer Projekt wirklich, und dann kam so, Gnare, bra,
bra, bra, bra, bra,
wo ich mir dachte, er kann nicht ganz verbergen,
wer sein Bot ist. Ja, das ist wie so ein Host, wie so
ein Changeling, der sich so in den Körper
einer normalen Mail reingefressen hat.
Ich mag euer Projekt wirklich Gnare, bra, bra,
rei. So, ich versuche ganz kurz mein Mailprogramm
zu öffnen, weil ich habe es gerade geschlossen und mein Mailprogramm ist
leider vom Teufel besessen, deswegen kann ich das oft nicht öffnen, aber nein, geht nicht. Und zwar habe ich eine Mail bekommen, wo dann drinsteht, sehr geehrter, meine E-Mail-Adresse, hätten Sie Interesse, sich als Test-Esser für die neue Ben-und-Jerry-Sorte zu bewerben. Wow. Also erst dachte ich, will ich das straight ernst. Ich dachte aber, es wäre auch eine Mail direkt an mich gerichtet. So von wegen, man will Florentin Will als Testimonial für Ben und Jerry. Er weiß offensichtlich, was gut schmeckt. Und schiebt sich einfach viel Eis in seine Kiemen. Und deswegen dachte ich, oh krass, dachte ich mir erst mal schade, weil ich kein Eis mehr essen kann. Aber deswegen dachte ich mir, fuck, aber dann dachte ich mir, nee, Moment mal, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach Spam und dann stand da tatsächlich, ja, es gibt bald eine neue Sorte und da wollen wir so einen Test machen und dann müssen sie dieses Formular ausfüllen, aber ich dachte mir, das ist eine gute Spam-Mail, weil viele Leute lieben Ben & Jerry's und zu sagen, es ist ja auch nicht, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, dass sie in so einer Marketingkampagne sagen, man schickt halt einfach ein paar Mails raus und will einfach
Testesser dieses Formular ausfüllen, so was ist
ihre Lieblingssorte jetzt oder wie viel Eis essen sie,
blablabla, deswegen finde ich es schon clever.
Ja, aber ich verstehe das nicht, ja klar,
also ich würde mal behaupten, wenn da cleverere Leute
dran sitzen, die wirklich Klicks haben wollen, einfach auch
Links, dann ist das doch nichts
einfacher als das, so Phishing-Mails.
Die wollen keine Klicks haben. Was ist denn mit diesen Mails,
die haben 1000 Euro gewonnen, dann kommt dieser Link, so die das denn noch? Aus meinem Vater vielleicht, der die Hundertzahre hat. Ich habe aber gelernt, was da dahinter steckt. Die wollen gar nicht, dass man auf diese Links draufklickt, sondern die registrieren, dass wenn du auf diesen Link draufklickst, dann wird die... Also wollen sie, dass sie auf den Link klickst. Naja, ja, aber nicht, dass du dann auf der Seite irgendwie ein Virus bekommst oder so, sondern... Nee, sondern dass die Mailadresse aktiv ist. dass die dann feststellen, ah, die Mailadresse ist noch in Benutzung und dann können die die teurer verkaufen an Werbeanbieter, weil die die Bestätigung und den Beweis haben, dass da die bestätigt werden. Dieses Gespräch fand Vice Versa auch schon mal statt, in dem neuen Podcast. Ja? Weil ich das glaube, ihr erzählt habt. Ja, das ist so eine Wellenbewegung. Alle 20 Folgen erklären sie sich gegenseitig die Wellen, immer der eine dem anderen. Die Dinge, die sie sich eigentlich erklärt haben. Ja, genau. Ja, das ist auch eine Wellenbewegung. Alle zwanzig Folgen erklären sie sich gegenseitig die Wellen, immer der eine dem anderen.
Die Dinge, die sie sich eigentlich erklärt haben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist auch immer schön, Leuten Dinge zu erklären, die sie selber besser wissen.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich interessant.
Vor allem, ich frage mich immer, warum das nicht besser funktioniert.
Also, wenn man Klick wählt, kriegt man den Klick.
Wirklich? Ist das so, Herr Titzner?
Ausser bei unserem Channel. Bei der Sketch-Comedy habe ich diesen Formel noch nicht geknackt. Ja, das ist noch Grauzone. Ey, empfiehlt mal den Channel, bitte. Also, empfiehlt mal, abonniert mal, empfiehlt ihn weiter, macht mal ein bisschen Werbung. Bongo Boulevard, auch ein toller Kanal des Funk-Netzwerks, hat ein Video rausgehauen, Rauen, wir brauchen mehr Klicks. So ein Song über wir brauchen mehr Klicks sagte mir, ja, wir kommen im Club. Aber die sind jetzt alle das Clever, das ist der gleiche Schiff. Das Clever, macht mal einen Song und die braucht mehr Klicks. Okay. Idee. Ich hab da was. Nee, die sind richtig cool. Hört euch mal, schaut mal ein paar Videos von Bokkebule an, die sind richtig geil. Aber ich dachte, bei Funk hat sich jetzt aus den Kinderschuhen rausgebt, dir noch mal eine Chance, schaut euch mal an. Hier Moritz Neumann, Christoph Niemann, Friedrich Staub, alles gute Leute, wo man einfach ein bisschen durchklicken kann. Guckt die einfach mal an. Guckt die alle mal an. Wo wir eben bei Dingen waren, die, wie ich glaube, mit krimineller Energie, ein bisschen mehr Brainpower, ein bisschen besser funktionieren könnten. Terroristen. Also, Florian und ich sind oft der Meinung, dass Terroristen nicht optimal effizient funktionieren, wie sie es könnten. Eleven war, gut, hat die Messlatte auch relativ hoch gesetzt, ist schon ganz clever gemacht, auch wie die es ausgeführt haben, ist schon in Perfektion. Da können sich viele Terroristen eine Scheibe von abschneiden. Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt, wir machen mal jetzt die Top 3, der Dinge, wie Terroristen besser eine Menschenmenge angreifen könnten. Okay? Die Top 3, der Dinge, wie Terroristen besser eine Menschenmenge angreifen könnten. Iiu, iiu, alu Akbar! Top drei! ein auf einer Seite, holst deine AK-47 raus, läufst einmal durch, dann haben wir es fallen, steigst aus, dann. Unmöglich, na gut, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich direkt verhaftet, wenn du ankommst. Aber darum gehst du ja nicht, du kannst ja auch sterben, du willst möglichst viele Menschen umbringen. Ja, aber in jedem ICE, in jedem Waggon... Wollen die das überhaupt... Das haben wir auch gefragt. In jedem Waggon sind vielleicht 50, 30 Leute, so ein ICE hat 10 Waggons, es sind 300 Leute. Damit wärst du schon der erfolgreichste Terrorangriff der jüngsten Geschichte seit 9-11 in Deutschland. Inwie vielen sind in Boston gestorben? 20? Lächerlich. Riesengrossastwahn. Wie sind Maun auflaufen? Naja gut. Bullshit. So, es geht viel einfacher. Meine dritte Art ist T-Shirt-Kanonen-Männer. Die Leute, die die T-Shirt-Kanonen befüllen mit T-Shirts. Warum? Es ist nichts leichter als das. Diesen Job kriegt man als Terrorist ganz einfach. Du musst nicht irgendwie die Army infiltrieren, du musst nicht große Konzerne infiltrieren, nein. Du musst einfach nur diesen T-Shirt-Kanonen-Mann, du wirst mit einer Kanone ins Stadion gelassen. Aber wäre es nicht besser, dann lieber nur die Kanonen zu manipulieren, die aber selber schießen zu lassen, dass du selber nicht mal der Täter bist, sondern die gar nicht merken, Moment mal, das ist die T-Shirt-Kanone. Mir gefällt, wie du denkst. Das ist ja ein Raketenwerfer. Okay, probier es mal. Und dann zack, du bist nicht mal selber schuld. Super, was du dir für Ideen einbringst. Genau das meine ich. Das ist total einfach. Oder einfach das T-Shirt ganz nah am Kopf ablösen. Ja. So maximal laden, dann pff, einfach so schön.
Ja.
Ja, ich meine, da ist auch die Möglichkeit drin.
Das war mein Top-Dies, das war mein Drei.
Platz Nummer zwei, Zug entgleisen.
Leute, nichts ist leichter als einen Zug zu entgleisen.
Du gehst irgendwo in Deutschland auf eine ICE-Strecke und machst da irgendwie die Gleise kaputt.
Das kannst du mitten in der Nacht machen. Das merken die doch. Hast du mal gesehen, wo ein ICE durchfährt? Nein. Hey, Gerd, hier ist so ein Licht! Und dann merken die sofort, oh, da ist das Gleis nicht mehr ganz dicht. Hast du mal gesehen, wo ein ICE durchfährt? Durch welche Wälder und Landschaften und so? Natürlich, da kannst du einfach hingehen, manipulierst die Gleise, zack, nächster Tag entgleist, 200 Tote, instant, kein Problem, hast du in einer halben Stunde gemacht.
Okay, mein Top zwei, die goldene Kamera.
Also man muss sich das, ich habe mir das vorgestellt vorher, wow, prestigeträchtiger,
renommierter Preis, wow, da muss ich bestimmt.
Viel Gold, ne?
Viel Gold, viel Silber, viel Stars, kommst du nicht einfach rein, da musst du entweder
ein Star sein, man erkennt dich, oder du musst halt diese
Eintrittskarte bekommen haben.
Tatsächlich, Sinkaterna und ich
haben uns mit dem Taxi dahin bringen lassen
und sind dann einfach
mit, weil man uns
wegen des Anzuges, den wir
anhatten, als Gäste identifiziert
automatisch, einfach reingelaufen.
Wir waren drin, wir standen dann mit allen Stars, Gerhard Delling, Günter Netzer, standen wir halt da rum, ohne dass uns irgendwann mal kontrolliert hat. Man kann einfach über den roten Teppich gehen und wird automatisch für einen Star gehalten. Du musst nicht einfach mit einem Taxi zu so einer Venue fahren und du kannst einfach reingehen. Niemand stellt in Frage, ob du ein Star bist. Und da waren auch Fans, die Colin Farrell oder so sehen wollten, die die ganze Gerufen haben, hey Colin, hey Colin, die in der Absperrung standen. Warum standen die hinter der Absperrung doch nicht mehr die ganze Zeit? Zieht euch einfach mal einen Anzug an, lasst euch mit dem Taxi vorfahren, ihr könnt einfach reingehen. Das ist nichts einfacher als das, sondern du bist in der Veranstaltungshalle. Und dann kannst du alle killen, alle Stars killen. Aber ist es denn besser, berühmte Leute zu töten als Terrorist? Also wenn du maximalen Einfluss auf die Kultur, maximal Hass zum Ausdruck bringen willst, gegen diese Freiheit lebende Kultur. Ja klar, wie ich sagen, das ist ein Top 1. Platz Nummer 1. Zwei Züge entgleisen lassen. ICE-Bordbistros vergiften. Ganz einfach, in dem ICE-Bordbistro arbeiten. Schön paar Kapseln Rattengift in das schöne fucking Schinken-Käse-Baguette. Das essen die wie die Schweine. Das essen die weg. Rap, rap, rap, rap, schön noch eins rein. Schön noch eins rein, schön noch eine Würstchensuppe rein daneben, zack, alle tot. Und wer war's? Niemand. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt nicht so... Okay, und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich euch diesen tollen Artikel gelesen, über so ein bisschen das Hauptmann vom Köpenick-Prinzip, wenn man sich eine Warnweste anzieht, kommst du überall rein, da habe ich noch so einen Artikel gelesen bei Weiss, da hat jemand einen Versuch gemacht und der war einfach bei einem Beyoncé-Konzert plötzlich, weil er eine Wahnweste anhat, musste nicht durch die Kontrollen, musste kein Ticket haben, einfach als Terrorist mal ein bisschen was investieren, müssen mir Gedanken machen, eine Wahnweste anziehen, du kommst überall rein, dieses Stadion und so, mit deiner Waffe, du wirst nicht kontrolliert. Ich habe letztens in Hamburg auch einen Spielplatz gesehen, ich habe mich nach einem Kindergarten... Du sollst nicht mehr auf Spielplätze gehen. Nein, Florian, wir haben darüber gesprochen, du sollst nicht mehr auf Spielplätze gehen. Ja, ich weiß. Du nimmst mir deine große Kamera mit, immer deinen großen Kopfhörer. Der Sand kitzelt meinen Hoden so schlimm. Da waren auf jeden Fall eine Menge Kinder unterwegs mit Erwachsenen und die hatten alle Warnwesten an. Alle Kinder hatten Warnwesten an. Und ich dachte mir schon, okay, gut, bauen die jetzt ihren eigenen Spielplatz auf oder was, machen die so eine Bauarbeit. Nee, ganz normal, die sind durch die Gegend gegangen und gelaufen und gespielt, aber jeder hatte eine kleine Warnweste an. Das hatten wir in der Skifreizeit auch. Jeder unserer Klasse hatte eine Warnweste
an. Und du willst auf der Piste natürlich auch
cool sein. Du willst der Coolste sein,
du willst dann auch mal die Nina,
die du kennengelernt hast auf der Hütte,
die willst du mal zeigen, was du für coole Kurven
drehen kannst. Na, aber das geht
halt nicht gut, wenn du eine Warnweste an hast
und alle, auch alle erfahrenen Fahrer
so Abstand nehmen, so, nee, fahrt ihr mal
erst mal. Ich finde, das hat einen ganz merkwürdigen Effekt, wenn die Kinder, weil das hat ja auch, also unabhängig davon, dass man jetzt so sagt, ja, Helikopterheldern, das hat ja auch so was Uniformes irgendwie so, also die sehen alle gleich aus, die sehen aus wie so diese Minions, die dann so durch die Gegend wackeln, und ich meine, die können sich auch nicht anschauen, die blenden sich ja gegenseitig, die strahlen sich ja kaputt, wenn du da einen... Und die erkennen sich auch nicht gegenseitig, nur am Geruch. Ja, wenn du ein Kind da in der Mitte bist, in so einem strahlenden Blitzlicht-Helios, bist du da drin. Und da zerschmilzt einfach wie so eine Ameise in so einer Lupe einfach so da runter. Also das fand ich ganz merkwürdig. Ich dachte mir auch so, Jesus, ey. Zum Beispiel, letztens hatten wir hier Alpakas auf dem Hof, und da war auch ein Kind von unserem Nachbarn, Kind war da, und das Kind ist standardmäßig einfach mit einem Helm durch die Gegend gelaufen. Mega geil, mega gut. Das kam nicht gerade vom Fahrradfahren oder sowas, sondern es hat einfach den ganzen Tag einen Helm auf. Ich finde es so ein lustiges Bild einfach. Ich will auch nicht ganz einfach einen Helm aufhaben. Ja, aber wo ich mir auch denke, also einerseits denkst du dir, das kann dadurch mehr Abenteuer machen, weil es hat ja einen Helm auf, oder es soll halt einfach, da wird halt komplett, mach gar nichts mehr, weil wenn du immer einen Helm auf hast, hast du ja die Gefahr immer vor, du denkst dir immer, oh, die Welt ist gefährlich, wenn du in die Welt gehst und einen Helm aufsetzt, denkt dein Kind ja immer, da draußen muss irgendwas Furchtbares sein. Und ist das nicht letztlich eine grössere Paranoia und ein schlechteres Weltgefühl, als wenn du einfach sagst, eigentlich ist es schon okay, gut, alle zwei Jahre fällt es halt mal auf die Fresse und dann ist dein Knie aufgeschürft oder alle zwei Wochen. Aber gut, was wirklich Schlimmes passiert nicht, als wenn du deinem Kind immer sagst, du willst raus, dann zieh dein Helm und deine Warnweste an. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dann denkt das Kind immer so, dann bleibe ich wieder drinnen, wie schlimm ist es denn da draußen? Da muss ich meinen Helm tragen, da muss ich noch meinen Watteanzug anhaben. Keine Ahnung, irgendwie merke ich nicht. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich meinem Kind auch einen Helm aufziehen würde. Klar, die ganze Zeit, ich würde auch selber die ganze Zeit einen Helm auftragen. Wie so ein Taucher, auch so Sauerstoff. Ja, falls du mal unter Wasser landest, dann kannst du wenigstens atmen. Mein Kind wäre auf alle Eventualitäten vorbereitet. Er hätte auch so einen Propeller auf dem Kopf. Das heißt, wenn die Situation scheiße ist, kannst du einfach wegfahren, abheben. Du kannst wie so eine Drohne abends einfach nach Hause fliegen soll. Es hebt einfach ab und fliegt zu dir nach Hause an Estes. Ist Bernardino nach Hause gekommen?
Mein Kind heißt Bernardino. Ist es nach Hause gekommen?
Nein, wie kann das denn sein?
Ich kümmere mich drum. Dann bin ich wirklich
ein Helikoptervater.
Aber eins im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
war ich mein Kind einfach nach Hause.
Und dann sieht man plötzlich so ein Blinken, bis etwas
vom Spielplatz nebenan aufsteigen.
Aber das ist doch der nächste Sprich.
Es gibt doch bald diese Amazon-Drohnen, die dir dein Paket nach Hause fliegen. Das kannst du doch einfach andersrum machen, so Kind abholen von zu Hause. Einfach mit so einer großen Zange, wie in so diesen Automaten, wo du so einen Bären und dann fällt der auch immer wieder so aus drei Metern Höhe, der fällt ja auch wieder durch den Clown und dann versucht das nochmal. Deswegen der Helm! Oder das fährt er nach Hause und dann hast du den einfach direkt wieder vor Arm. Das finde ich keine schlechte Idee. Plötzlich ist die ganze Welt wie so ein Videospiel, wo man auch mal diese grosse Hand war, die man von A nach B Dinge getragen hat einfach. Das ist eine ganz gute Idee eigentlich. Das stimmt schon. Neulich wurde auch so ein Haus aus einem 3D-Drucker gebaut. Das ist schon geil. Das war der Grösse. Wie gross war der 3D-Drucker? Gross. Gröser als das Haus. Und es sah dann aus wie so ein Monopoly-Haus, so ganz grün, außer einem Guss. Dies der 3D-Drucker? Gross, grösser als das Haus.
Und es sah dann aus wie so ein Monopoly-Haus, so ganz grün, außer einem Guss.
Fun fact, diesen 3D-Drucker hat auch einen 3D-Drucker gebaut.
Oh scheiße, da wird es gefährlich, da wird es gefährlich.
Finde ich auch.
Stell dir mal vor, als 3D-Drucker würde ich einen 3D-Drucker bauen, der meine Arbeit macht.
Wäre das nicht die beste Idee?
Ja, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum ein 3D-Drucker ist noch eine dumme Idee, warum nicht gleich 4D-Drucker? Warum nicht einfach sagen, Leute, scheiße, auf die dritte Dimension, da haben wir uns jetzt lange genug aufgehalten. Die Fesseln der dritten Dimension. Vor allem ist Zeit ja die vierte Dimension, heisst, du hast quasi einen Vierdrucker ja schon da, weil er ja auch eine gewisse Zeit braucht, um das zu drehen. Drucken, glaube ich. Naja, aber du kannst die Zeit ja nicht manipulieren so. Das kannst du generell nicht. Ja eben, aber mit einem 4D-Drucker könntest du es ja eben schon. Man kann ihn, glaube ich, nicht bauen. Aus physischen Gründen. Wir haben übrigens heute einen interessanten Artikel gelesen, und zwar ist es einer Forschergruppe aus Amerika gelungen, endlich das Geheimnis des Menschen zu entschlüsseln, und zwar haben die irgendwie Überreste gefunden von einem Mann aus dem 14. Jahrhundert, also Mittelalter irgendwo aus England, und die haben sich einfach gesagt so, hm, wie sahen denn Menschen damals aus im 14. Jahrhundert? Mega gute Idee, mega gute Frage, die konnten es nachbauen, die haben versucht nachzubauen, die haben jahrelang daran gearbeitet. Man kennt ja so Neandertaler, irgendwie so Ötzi, so krass, irgendwie wie so ein halber Affe, irgendwie so krass, so sahen unsere Vorfg. Bisschen kleiner, man denkt sich so, krass, hat sich viel getan
in der Welt. Und die haben rekonstruiert
von diesem Mann aus dem 13. Jahrhundert
und heute haben sie es tatsächlich geschafft, seit
mehrjähriger Forschung haben sie es geschafft, eine Computersimulation,
sie haben dann also die Knochen genommen, so den Schädel analysiert,
was eine Rampe, so ein bisschen Gewebe gemacht
und dann haben sie einfach analysiert, wie der ganze aussagt.
Und heute haben sie das Foto veröffentlicht und
es sieht aus wie ein komplett
normaler Mensch aus der Neuzeit. Random Guy. Einfach random, hat sich nicht verändert, sieht sogar aus wie so ein Schauspiel. Einfach Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, ob die einfach mega enttäuscht waren, als sie einfach Millionen Forschungsgerinnern, ja, da sieht man ein bisschen aus dem Marco, oder? Dann setzen sie das letzte Puzzleteil zusammen, sieht besonders wie mein Nachbar. Ja, einfach so, ich denke so, fuck, oder sie haben es einfach nicht hingekriegt,
das Ganze zu sagen, und haben eigentlich gesagt, ja,
dann machen wir einfach so einen Typen, machen die Nase ein bisschen
größer und das passt dann schon. Ich stelle mir vor,
wenn jemand so ein Dinosaurier nachbaut
und endlich das Dinosauriergesicht machen kann,
und das einfach auch so ein Menschengesicht ist,
was genau so aussieht.
Stegosaurus mit so grossen
Spikes, so grosse, einfach so
grosse Stacheln, die weggehen, aber das
Gesicht ist einfach ganz normal. So eine neueste
Forschung, so sahen Dinosaurier wirklich
Vielen Dank. Dinosauris mit so grossen Spikes, einfach so grossen Stacheln, die weggehen. Aber das Gesicht ist einfach ganz normal. So eine neueste Forschung, so sahen Dinosaurier wirklich aus. Und dann habe ich so einen Hugo Egon Balder gesehen. Auch eine Frisur, eine schicke Frisur. Vor allem, der Typ hat auch den Bart geschnitten, der aus dem Mittelalter. Ja, warum nicht? Ja, was machen? Sein Papiergen ist ja kein Ding. Gut im Mittelalter Wissen immer. Ja, ja, aber es ist schon lustig. Wie sahen Menschen auch ganz aus. Du hast mich eben gefragt, ob ich was hören kann auf meinen Kopfhörern. Du hast heute irgendwas ganz Besonderes vor für diese Folge. Du hast doch gerade was ganz, du hast doch, was ist denn mit dir eigentlich los? Du hast dich doch gerade so schelmisch grinsend an deinen Rechner gesetzt und gefragt, ob ich das höre, weil du irgendwas vorbereitet hast offensichtlich. Naja, ich dachte, wir könnten heute mal, weil ich habe mich ein bisschen in eine Puffopedia umgetrieben. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das machen wir jetzt nicht, nein, nein, nein. Und dachte ich mal, wir machen heute mal eine kleine Analyse. Nee, komm, aber dann darf ich mir das Lied auch aussuchen. Naja, weiß ich auch nicht. Nee, komm, das ist aber ein bisschen, das ist gemein. Ja, komm. Aber dann darf ich mir das Lied auch aussuchen. Na, weiß ich auch nicht.
Nee, komm, das ist aber ein bisschen, das ist gemein.
Ja, gut.
Das ist, oh, okay, mach, aber na gut, muss ich so stehen.
Er spielt auf meine Band-Vergangenheit an.
Ihr habt alles gefunden von mir.
Ich bin ein offenes Buch.
Ich habe keine Geheimnisse mehr für euch, gar nichts.
Ihr wisst alles über mich mittlerweile.
Ihr habt meine ganze Vergangenheit offen gelegt im Internet. Das Internet ist echt die Hölle. Man ist auch einfach mittlerweile so ein gläserner Mensch. Ja, wir haben die alte Bandvergangenheit von Stefan Tietze gefunden. Und wenn ihr denkt, X-Faktor habe ich alles schon 200 Mal gesehen. Ich muss das alles löschen lassen. Habe ich alles schon 200 Mal gesehen. Dann wisst ihr eben nicht, was los ist, denn, Stefan, sag doch mal ganz kurz, es gab ja vor Binky Sack Bu tatsächlich noch eine Band. Es gab mehrere Bands, aber die anderen findet ihr gar nicht mehr, weil das zu alt ist, aber das, ja, X-Pack gab es, die Vorgängerband. Erzähl doch mal ein bisschen was über X-Pack. Nee, da gibt es nicht so viel zu erzählen, es war die gleiche Band, wir haben uns irgendwann umbenannt Und wir hatten ein paar Songs, die du jetzt bestimmt spielst.
Und hier ist ein Song, den ich ganz besonders gut fand, der heisst Duschlampe.
Und den hören wir uns jetzt mal an.
Und vielleicht kann Tizze da so ein bisschen was dazu sagen.
Der Text ist ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen.
Deswegen, wir hören mal ganz kurz rein.
Alter, es ist laut!
Hat aber Wumms!
Wo war das denn, die Aufnahme?
Das war in Menden.
In Menden in Sauerland. Wir waren die Vorband von Extrabreit.
Ja? Extrablatt?
Extrabreit. Ich hör dich nicht mehr.
Ich versteh dich auch nicht.
Aber erzähl mal so ein bisschen. Kannst du den Text noch?
Ich höre mich gerade nicht.
Kannst du den Text noch?
Schlampe, ich brauche dich nicht.
Schlampe, ich brauche dich.
Und bist du, dass du der singt gerade? Ja, ich singe. Ja, okay, geil, ihr könnt den Song euch komplett anhören. Spielen wir den rein? Ja. Ich hab die Rechte ja daran. Machen wir uns mal wieder lauter auf dem Kopfhörer. Wir hören die anderen jetzt hoffentlich. Ja, ihr könnt den Song anhören, vielleicht würde ich ihn auch in kompletter Länge hier einfügen an der Stelle. Da werden wir mal reinhören. Und es war so interessant... Oh, ein Augeleis. Ganz Auge, ganz Auge. Ja, und es war interessant, das zu hören, weil jeder kennt ja die Songs von Bing and Abu, ne, ist ja mittlerweile auch im Alkanon angekommen. Und ich fand's eigentlich tatsächlich ganz cool. Also ihr wart ja echt jung und es war so die erste Band, aber wie fühlt sich das an? Wie fühlt sich das an? Das Ding, also es fühlt sich komisch an ein bisschen, aber Duschlampe ist natürlich ein Song, der ist natürlich stark bekannt gewesen. Die Leute haben wieder auf dem Schulhof gesungen. Duschlampe war ein Song, den unser Keyboarder geschrieben hat, der Simon, der der Song handelt von einer Frau, mit der man Schluss gemacht hat. Und es lässt sich im Punk-Rück verordnen. Wir sind in der Tonrad G-Duo geschrieben worden. Hat ungefähr, ja, schon schnell, 180 BPM und aus dem Jahre 2000 und 2009. Ich habe das angeschaut, ich dachte so von wegen, ah, jetzt kann man sich so ein bisschen über Stefan lustig machen, so von wegen, aber ich fand, das war eigentlich ganz cool, so, wie kam es dir der Aufnahme, was war das für ein, was war das für ein, was war das für ein, das war ein relativ grosser Auftritt, wir haben, wir wurden die beste Band von Dortmund gewählt, das beste Band von Dortmund gewählt, so ein kleiner Bandwettbewerb, wo nicht alle Bands von Dortmund mitgemacht haben. Was auch so ein bisschen ist, ich bin der beste Lasertag-Spieler Spanien. Tatsächlich, der beste Taube.
Und das war, ja, war ganz cool eigentlich so.
Und das war auch ein seltsamer Wettbewerb, wo der Organisator des Wettbewerbs offensichtlich nicht wollte, dass wir gewinnen.
Warum nicht?
Weil der sich in eine Band verliebt hat, die auch mitgemacht hat da.
Die war auch wesentlich besser als wir, die waren richtig gut.
Und dann hat er, die hieß Logic Insanity, wir hießen X-Pack und dann gab's noch The Roundhouse-Kicks. Und er hat, das waren die drei Bands, und der Organisator ist auf die Bühne gegangen, hat gesagt, heute sind bei uns zu Gast X-Cept, Nope, Logic Incidents, Nope, und The Run Kickers, viel Spaß. Echt? Ja alle so, wo, wo, wo, wo, alle drei falsch ausgesprochen, mega geil.
Und er wollte unbedingt, dass Logic Insanity gewinnt, weil es war auch die bessere Band einfach.
Aber wir hatten einfach die meisten Fans dann da mitgebracht und dann haben wir gewonnen einfach so.
Er war mega enttäuscht und dann wurden wir die Vorband von Extra Breit.
Das war der Aufsicht, den ich gerade gehört habe. Da waren wir die Vorband von Extrabreit, eine ganz coolen Band eigentlich, eine coole Punkband aus Deutschland. Und da haben wir dann einen grossen Auftritt gehabt in Menden, in der Mendener Halle. Und ja, da haben wir dann ein paar Songs gespielt von uns. Er kam Gehtso an. Generell kamen die meisten Auftritte von uns Gehtso an. Bei einem der Songs, ich glaube, es ist der Song Lang nicht genug. Oh Gott, aber der ist textlich miserabel. Da hört man am Anfang auch noch so, ja, ne, ne, ne, wo wirklich so Stimmung gemacht wird. Und obwohl es nur eine Audioaufnahme ist, kommt schon so rüber, dass es nicht so, aber es ist natürlich schwierig. So eine Crowd zu begeistern, ist natürlich nicht einfach, das wissen wir selber auch. Ich habe die schon ein paar Mal gesehen
im Internet, dass die noch existent sind.
Ich finde es bei diesem Auftritt okay, weil
der ist tatsächlich, der klingt auch so,
da sind wir zum ersten Mal, glaube ich,
seit jemals waren wir da okay abgemischt,
hatten eine coole Halle,
es war relativ gross, man hört, es heilt auch
so ein bisschen, es klingt alles noch ein bisschen grösser.
Da gibt es Auftritte,
wenn die im Internet landen, ist meine Karriere beendet.
Es gibt wirklich, wo wir auch
dann aufgehört haben, irgendwann zu singen
Vielen Dank. Das klingt alles noch ein bisschen größer. Da gibt es Auftritte, wenn die Mitte der Landen, ist meine Karriere beendet.
Es gibt wirklich, wo wir auch dann aufgehört haben, irgendwann zu singen
und einfach so ein Stand-Up improvisiert haben.
So was ganz fragwürdig
und auch ganz furchtbar war.
Und so, das war wirklich seltsam.
Einmal waren wir auf einem
Heissluftballonfestival haben wir gespielt.
Und ich glaube,
die Erinnerung, die ich daran habe...
Das Publikum war alle 400 Meter in der Höhe.
Sie ist einfach vor uns weggeflogen, wirklich.
Weil wir zu spät angefangen haben,
weil das Publikum vor uns einfach weggeflogen hat.
Das ist mein ...
So mit Blickkontakt, einfach so.
Ciao, hey, gut, Zugabe, Zugabe, weg.
Wie können Heißluftballons singen? Zeppelin-Festival, einfach so. Was ist das Publikum? Winken noch so. Winken noch bis Spaß. Die Band winkt auch und bauen dann langsam ab. Cooler wäre es, als Band wegzufliegen. Wenn du als Band merkst, der Aufritt läuft nicht so gut und du dann sagst, oh sollen wir noch einen spielen? Oh, ich merke, wir hauen langsam ab, wir fliegen schon los, dann bist du einfach weg. Ja, Bandzeit. Geil. Ich wollte eigentlich die Leute motivieren, mal auf Puffopedia vorbeizuschauen, Puffopedia.info, da könnt ihr euch den Artikel von X-Packt, fängt mit X an, anschauen und dann könnt ihr mehr überfahren über Stephans Titzel-Titzel-Erfahrung. Wie geht's da weiter, Titzel-Titzel-Titzel-Titzel? Nee, es wäre Titzel. Ich könnte wieder umändern. Leider ist die lustige Zeit vorbei. Ich hab ja meinen richtigen Ausweis. Schade. Somit ist dann die Reisepass-Storyline ein für alle Mal beendet. Gibt's noch ein Revival? Ich glaub, da kommt noch was. Da kommt noch ein Sequel. Bestimmt kommt da noch was. Ist ein bisschen traurig, weißt du, weil so ist es halt bei Sitcoms auch. Manchmal enden halt so Storylines dann einfach, die sind einfach vorbei, die sind abgeschlossen, zu denen erzählt. Was meinst du, was kommt als nächstes für eine Storyline irgendwie in deinem Leben? Was gibt's noch irgendwie, gibt's ein neues Hobby, gibt's irgendwie mal eine Dame in deinem Leben, was weißt du was, freut euch mal bitte auf ein Projekt, was demnächst von mir kommt. Also ich darf da noch nichts drüber sagen, aber du weißt ja schon davon. Ich fre freue mich, ich freue mich, oh mein Gott, ne, ich mache demnächst was krasses, und da könnt ihr mal noch, da freut ihr euch mal drauf. Flotin macht sowieso krassen Scheiss die ganze Zeit, könnt ihr gucken, aber das ist krass. Aber was meinst du, wann kann man da die ersten Früchte sehen? Weiß ich nicht, ich glaube, ganz abstrakt erstmal nur. Ich glaube, 2019 bestimmt. Oh, okay, ja, da müsst ihr auf jeden Fall bis dann dranbleiben, an dem Stefan-Tieteezer-Hype-Trade. Ich halte mich auch im Laufen, aber merkt euch diese Folge, Folge 94, hier wurde es angeteased. Ja. Ja, alles klar. Gut, ja, das war's. Du musst ja auch jetzt gehen, oder nicht, warst du eben gesagt? Ich habe noch Sachen. Ja, dann hab ich da raus, ne, ich muss nicht gehen, ich habe heute Abend. Das ist nichts zu wahr? Wir können auch, ich muss heute noch laufen gehen heute. Laufen gehen? Ja, ich will wieder laufen gehen. Ach, ich will wieder... Ach, ich hab heute Abend ... Das ist nicht so wahr? Ich muss heute noch laufen gehen. Laufen gehen? Ja, ich will wieder laufen gehen. Das ist so hegelhaft. Ich will wieder einmal pro Woche mindestens joggen gehen. Aber es ist so scheiße, weil du sitzt ja einfach da ... Aber in Köln joggen gehen, weil du wohnst in einer Beton-Umgebung. Ja, nicht in der Mediapark, aber doch, ich glaube, Medienpark. Mediapark. Nee, es ist nicht der Mediapark. Es ist, du meinst Aachener Weiher, glaube ich. Nee, es gibt so ein kleines Parkstück, da gibt es auch so einen kleinen Hügel, wo er immer steht, mit den Armen in den Hüften und sich über die Köln schaut und denkt, ha, meine Stadt. Ja, es geht schon so halb, aber es ist einfach so, man hat keinen Bock, man denkt sich, es ist so viel Aufwand und ich kann auch einfach weniger an mich reinschieben, das würde einen ähnlichen Effekt haben. Aber dann ist es immer so. Ist das so? Ja, ich träg's mich immer aus. Ich denk mir immer so, wenn ich esse, denk ich mir, ja, ich geh auch heute Abend noch laufen, aber wenn ich dann kurz vor mir zu laufen, denk ich mir, ja, ich kann ja morgen einfach weniger essen und dann ist es so hin und her so und es löst sich nie auf und ich hab aus beiden Welten das Schlechteste und dadurch geht's einfach nie voran, das ist einfach scheiße. Ja, mein Gott. Ja, mal gucken, mal gucken. Vielleicht, ich erzähle, ob ich es schaffe, jetzt wieder jede Woche zu laufen. Ja, erzähl mal, bleib mal dran. Das ist eine Storyline, die mir Spaß macht. Weil ich kann, seit Jahren kann die mich dazu motivieren, Sport zu machen. Ich will es einfach nicht. Ich bin irgendwann zu einem gnadenlosen Hedonisten übergegangen und mache nur noch Dinge, wo ich mir denke, die machen mir jetzt Spaß im Moment. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber bin ich bereit, irgendwas zu investieren. Ich hasse es zu essen, ich hasse es Dinge zu machen, die nichts unmittelbar mir bringen, meinen Geist voranzutreiben. Das Problem an so Sport ist einfach, es ist so leicht, es nicht zu machen. Es ist leichter, es ist am leichtesten, es nicht zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, wie man diese Dynamik erinnern könnte, aber es wäre irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich wohne auf einem Berg und ich muss jeden Tag diesen Berg runterlaufen und danach wieder diesen Berg hochlaufen. Würde ich das machen, weil ich es nicht anders kann, aber Sport, du musst es einfach nicht machen, du denkst dir einfach, Och nö, und dann lässt du es einfach und dann warst du es, die ganze
Vorfreude war dann weg.
Ich glaube, ich bin vielleicht einfach zu intelligent,
ich kann mir zu viele Argumente ausdenken,
es nicht zu tun, es ist das
Logischste der Welt, Joggen zu gehen
ist nur gut, es ist gut für deine Figur,
für dein Aussehen, für deine Gesundheit,
für deine, was heisst ich, Gelenke oder
irgendeinen Shit-Blutdruck, alles ist besser,
du fühlst dich besser, du kannst auch
besser denken und besser arbeiten, weil
Vielen Dank. für dein Aussehen, für deine Gesundheit, für deine, was weiß ich, Gelenke oder irgendeinen Shit-Blutdruck, alles ist besser, du fühlst dich besser. Das ist nicht gut für die Knie, glaube ich. Du kannst auch besser denken und besser arbeiten, weil dein Körper irgendwie auch mal irgendwie neue Synapsen formt und irgendwie so ein bisschen andere, keine Ahnung, du wirst einfach besser. Er merkt, wie intelligent er ist an seinen vielen Fremdworten, die er benutzt und den wenigen Füllwörtern, die er gerade in der Ausgabe gesehen hat. Aber dann fallen dir dazu einfach noch so viele Gegenargumente ein, wie denkst du, ja, aber man könnte ja auch einfach gar nichts machen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das sind so viele Argumente, die laufen einfach auch kein Ziel. Ich meine, das Ziel ist, im Kreis zu laufen. Und der Weg ist das Ziel, offensichtlich, bei nichts mehr als bei Joggen. Aber no, das reicht mir einfach nicht. Hättest du mal Bock, irgendwie keine Ahnung, einfach zu sagen, einmal in der Woche abends Federball spielen oder sowas? Klar. Wirklich? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Squash. Ja, Squash ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu kass, oder? Federball finde ich ganz geil. Vor allem, wir könnten überlegen, ob wir einfach das bei Periscope livestreamen, einfach jede Woche. Denn Harmen macht das, denn Harmen filmt sich jeden Morgen wie er auf seinem Heimtrainer. Ja, genau. Einfach, um aber auch von der Community den Druck zu bekommen. Wollen wir das so ein neues Projekt machen? Der Sommer 2017 ist der Get Fit mit dem Podcast UFO Sommer. Immer wenn ihr, aber ihr dürft euch den Periscope Stream nur anschauen, wenn ihr währenddessen auch selber Sport macht. Oh, das finde ich supergut. Wir machen jetzt so eine Supersportaktion und wir einmal in der Woche Get Fit, wir machen mit beim Fossieben Get Fit denn! Gesponsor vom Gesundheitsministerium der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Fit macht fun! Und wir stellen uns flot. Fit kann auch lustig. Genau. Und dann machen wir uns so T-Shirts. Fit kann auch lustig. Könnt ihr mal bitte unsere beiden Gesichter mit so, wir machen ein Foto von euch, vor grün, mit so Stirnband und so wirklich zu engen Hosen. Genau, und dann schreibt ihr mal da drunter mit einem coolen Font, schreibt ihr dann, Fit kann auch lustig. Oder lustig kann auch fit, auf einem das eine, auf dem anderen das andere. Wir machen Shirts, wir machen Shorts und Shirts, spielen wir einmal die Woche, spielen wir Badminton. Genau, schick das an BTF GmbH Leindeindeggerstrasse 27 in Köln und wir fangen an, wir fangen an, ohne Scheiß, für Stefan M, für mich XXL einfach und an Periscope, wir machen einmal im Abend, spielen wir Badminton und wir werden gemeinsam fit, der knackige Beachbody, zusammen mit dem Podcast-UFO. Das finde ich richtig cool. Also, wir heben uns mal ab von diesen ganzen Slacker-Podcasts, weißt du, so Gästelisse, Geisterbahn, Nukulase, wir schauen Adam-Sander-Film und schieben uns Chips rein. Nein, diese Lethargie bleibt mal zurück dieses Jahr. Wir machen mal Sport mal, fit macht Fun, Leute, wuh! Vor allem Badminton ist ja so eine unkönne Sportart, wo man ja, wenn man das professionell spielt, aus irgendeinem Grund spielen die weltbesten Badminton-Spieler mit so unfassbar kurzen Shorts. Ja. Das ist irgendwie, also braucht ihr das? Ich glaube, das war brutal anstrengend, oder? Ich glaube, man kann das auch exakt so professionell mit einer langen Jogginghose, mit einer Jeans. Die könnten sich die Jeans anziehen bei Olympia, so die könnten gewinnen. Als ob der jetzt besser ist, weil er die kürzeste Shorts der Welt trägt. Was meinst du denn, wer gewinnt von uns beiden? Ich bin größer, das Netz ist kein Hinweis für mich. Oder nachduschen.
Nee, das mache ich zu Hause.
Oder vielleicht mit Badehose.
Ich bin voll in der Badehose.
Aber wir sind ja beide, ich war früher mal beim Fussball, da habe ich auch mit anderen geduscht, aber seitdem bin ich es nicht gewohnt.
Ich habe noch nie mit anderen geduscht.
Mit meinem Geschlecht offen umzugehen. Habe ich auch nie gelernt tatsächlich. Aber es ist ganz normal, das zu lernen, wenn man ein Team tut. Ja, das stimmt. Ich glaube, ich war ja vor der Pubertät in einem Verein. Ich habe Handball gespielt und dann auch Tischtennis und Karate und so. Aber die Phase habe ich da nicht miterlebt. Warst du bei Karate fett? Nee, ich glaube, na, hat so angefangen. Ich müsste immer alte Fotos rauskramen, aber da noch nicht so. Aber das habe ich so diese, diese Offenheit mit dem eigenen Körper habe ich nie gelernt. So, ich glaube, ich hätte da wirklich große Hemmungen, würde ich auch nicht einfach nicht machen. Nee, würde ich auch nicht machen, glaube ich auch nicht. Aber früher war das, würde ich so auch, zur pubertären Zeit, habe ich Fussball gespielt und da war das kein Problem. Einfach, schön war. Ich weiss nicht, wie ich diesen Satz auch humoristisch zu Ende bringen soll. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, ich hätte dann auch so Bock, so richtig, ey, da machen wir das große Podcast-Ufo-Badminton-Turnier. Und ich hätte dann auch Bock, ich würde mir auch so einen richtig coolen Badminschläger kaufen. Ich würde mich da massiv reinsteigern. Ich würde mir so eine Profi-Badminton-Uniform kaufen. So ein Stirnband vom 1. FC Darmstadt bestimmt, Badminton-Meister 2003, so würde mir dann auch einen krassen Schläger besorgen, krasse Federbälle. Aber ich würde wahrscheinlich... Du nimmst aber auch Federball, oder? Ja klar, ich würde aber wahrscheinlich langfristig mich für einen Sport-BH entscheiden, weil ich habe empfindliche Nippel, es ist wirklich so, die scheuert dann und die werden immer härter und härter und bre sprechen dann so durchs T-Shirt durch und spritzen Blut in den anderen ins Gesicht. Und das ist einfach nervig. Ich glaube, langfristig, ich glaube, ich würde eine sehr erbärmliche Figur geben, aber ich würde dich fucking fertig machen. Ey, das finde ich wirklich nicht schlecht. Ja, freu dich drauf. Das ist der große Fit kann auch lustig Sommer mit das Podcast-Hofo. Ey, wenn das jemand in die Hand nimmt und uns diese T-Shirt-Scheve machen wir auf jeden Fall. Unten muss das Bundesministerium für
Gesundheit, muss unten auf dem Sinne das
Logo reinkommen. Ey, vielleicht machen wir das wirklich im Zusammenspiel
mit dem Bundesministerium für Gesundheit.
Warum nicht? Kann auch cool sein.
Ja, Sport kann auch lustig,
fit sein,
das Podcast sucht. Ey, wenn mal auf der
offiziellen Homepage des
Bundesministeriums für Gesundheit
auf der Facebook und wir so mit so Daumen hoch und sagen, lustig kann auch fit und fit kann auch lustig. Und wir wirklich so mit Unterstützung des Bundesministeriums für Gesundheit und Arbeit. Wenn wir das wirklich machen, ey, das finde ich, das wäre der Sieg. Das wäre der Sieg für mich, für das Podcast-Fail. Vor allem, ich will einfach den Link podcast-uwe.fail auf dem Bundesministerium für Gesundheit. Ja, mir eine gute Idee. Das ist richtig lustig. Wir gucken uns mal um, wo wir in Köln das machen können. Und vielleicht machen wir es auch mit Publikum irgendwann. Wir machen es jede Woche. Und ihr könnt kommen. Es bilden sich so Teams und so verschiedene Moves. Ja, weiß ich noch nicht. Na ja, mal gucken. Erstmal privat. Geil, aber habt ihr auf jeden Fall das wird ein geiler Sommer.
Aber privat machen wir das nicht.
Deswegen finde ich diese Ebene ganz gut.
Wir sind auch Leute, wir machen auch was fürs Publikum dann.
Ich glaube, es hilft einem auch,
so einen Druck von euch zu bekommen, Sport zu machen.
Podcast UFO macht uns und euch sexy für den
Sommer 2017. Es wird ein geiles Projekt.
Sport macht Spaß und
Spaß macht Sport und ihr seid live mit dabei
bei podcastufo.de.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
Ciao, wir heben ab.